I have a right to be happy I have a
right to be unhappy you'll hear people
say it all the time I have a right to be
miserable and they go around defending
their right to be miserable and when you
defend your right to be miserable you
attract exactly what you're defending
into your life you just keep attracting
more and more of it I was attracting the
wrong people into my life I was eating
improperly I was putting caffeine into
my body I was a a candidate for every
kind of illness you could imagine and
everything in my life changed give up
your personal history Give It Up let go
of it don't be attached to it Wayne Dyer
was an icon in self-development and
spiritual growth he wrote over 40 books
with an astonishing 21 New York Times
bestsellers his childhood was spent in
orphanages and Foster homes but he'd go
on to inspire millions and become known
as the father of motivation in this
exclusive speech from the celebrate your
life stage Wayne Dyer shares with us the
keys to attracting success living in
harmony with the universe and unleashing
the profound power of intent attention
special thanks to Liz Don for partnering
with us to release this exclusive
content on our YouTube channel enjoy let
me start with the first of these uh 10
secrets for success in inner peace a
good place to start have a mind that is
open to everything and attached to
nothing it is a principle that I learned
when I was reading years ago in my 30s a
book called The discourses of tilopa
written in the 10th Century thousand
years ago in India the dantic scholar
and he was suggesting that a closed mind
is one that says my experiences have
taught me that that's not possible I
suggest to you that you change that and
rid yourself of that kind of a of a
thought if someone says I would like to
teach you to levitate don't
automatically assume that levitation is
impossible if I were to ask by a show of
hands how many people in this room
believe it's possible for you to
levitate all of you would be right
whether you raised your hand or you
didn't if you don't believe that it's
possible it won't be if you do and you
decide to put unbending intent on it it
will become I was in Boston
Massachusetts one time and I watched the
yogic flyer what a fascinating
experience they sit with their bodies in
a yoga position that is their legs
crossed and their hands crossed and I
would like you to imagine yourself in
that position with your hands up here
and both of your legs cross together in
a yoga position and then I would like to
ask you how high do you think you could
raise yourself up through your will and
they took the greatest gymnastic Olympic
athletes and the highest any of them
were ever able to get was about 5 1/2 in
off the ground and they couldn't stay at
all they went up and right back down
these are the people who have the
strongest muscles and the most the
greatest athletes if you will and we
watched these yogic flyers and they had
a they had six rows and they had all six
of them sitting here and then they had
hurdles 24in High hurdles on in every
lane 24 in high low hurdles and they had
I think eight of them or maybe 10 and
then they had a mat at the end of the
wall down here and they were having
races the yogic flyer races the Olympics
I love this and off they would go and
they would start bouncing bouncing
bouncing bouncing bounc with and their
eyes bouncing bouncing and they'd come
to the hurdle and they would go deep
within and their bodies would go up and
over the hurdle and they go back down
and they go their bodies would go up
they'd go over the Hur and they did this
for six or eight hurdles 24 in off the
ground and a few of them sort of were
showing off they would just stay above
the hurdle for a second or two I love
those guys now if you think that
something like that is impossible if you
think I'm making it up or if you think
that defies all all the laws of science
that we know I would like to remind you
that the laws of science come from the
same place that your doubt comes from
and it came comes from the same place
that everything in this universe come
from when a great teacher in India was
asked by his one of his devotees the
great question where does everything
come from he responded where does your
question come from and it is out of that
void it is out of that Spirit out of
that Consciousness that everything
emanates everything is Creator and if
you have a closed mind to that and
Anthony Dello reminded us that almost
all of our attachments are the things
that are the source of all of our
problems our attachments primarily our
attachments to being right our
attachments to money our attachments to
our belief systems our attachments to
our beliefs I mean so many people here
really strongly I've heard it expressed
since I've been here far Friday many of
you believe that the real person who
needs to hear all of these messages is
not here he's back home home watching
the football games and you are far more
spiritually Advanced and that represents
you know the consciousness of uh what
your relationships are like there's the
spiritual one and there's that
that's back at home or whoever it is and
I'd like to suggest to you that that
person back at home who you interpret to
be the one who really needs to hear this
message that he or she or they are in
your life for as profound a reason as
anyone you've heard here these last
weekend that they have as much to teach
you and I really and truly don't believe
that our soulmates are the people that
we agree with I believe that I mean I
heard a woman say one time oh I finally
found my soulmate oh it's so wonderful
he's a republican just like
me he likes asparagus I like asparagus
we read the same books we both read I go
to say something and he says it before I
even get a chance to get it we are so
connected I said that's not your
soulmate any relationship and with two
people agree on everything one of them
is
unnecessary your soulmate is the person
that pushes your buttons your soulmate
is the person that that can send you
into a frenzy your soulmate is the
person who if uh if if 99 people out of
a 100 say something to you you're able
to ignore it but when they say it you go
insane
that's your
soulmate and they never
disappear you can't get rid of them
they're like the proverbial turd that
won't flush you
know you flush you walk away you said
couldn't be back couldn't be I thought I
got rid of you showed up again because
your essence what you're here for is
about peace it's about peace it's about
being in Rapport or in harmony with that
which created you out of which you came
and I'll speak about that when I speak
about intention and anytime you're out
of raor out of Harmony inconsistent with
that Source from which you emanated
you're out of peace and anybody who can
send you away from your peace is someone
who came into your life to teach you the
most important lessons that you have my
father walked out on our family when I
was born he never made a phone call to
my mother who had three boys under the
age of four during the Depression he
spent 5 years of his life in prison he
did the same thing to five additional
wives he died of sosis of the liver at
the age of 49 in debt to everyone a
thief and he never even made a phone
call never sent a penny and support he
just walked out I had my 60th birthday 2
years ago my mother was sitting there
next to me and she said 60 years ago
this week I came home and your father
who you never saw had left the house
left a note left your brother Jim in
charge of your brother Dave your brother
Jim was 3 and A2 your brother Dave was
17 months old very sick and he left a
note and took all of the jewelry and
everything we had in the house of value
and said he had moved in with another
woman who was living in an arbor at the
time this was on the east side of
Detroit on Piper Street and she still
Harbors resentment towards this man but
in 1974 10 years after he died I went to
his grave and I was able to express one
of those 10 Secrets which is give up
your personal history give it up let go
of it don't be attached to
it as cator says if you don't have a
story you don't have to live up to
it so get rid of your story because
everything that has ever happened to you
in the past is nothing more than what
you had to go go through in order to get
here pretty simple the evidence for it
is that you did you don't really need
much more evidence than that and you're
everything that happen back there is
like the wake of a boat the wake of a
boat is nothing more than a trail that
is left behind and it doesn't drive the
boat the Wake can never drive the boat
it's just a trail that is left behind
and most of us who take on egos believe
that the wake of our life is what's
driving the boat that trail that is left
back there is why I can't do this in the
10th Century there was a man named Omar
kayam a Muslim who wrote the ruat
imagine a thousand years ago he knew
this the moving finger writes and having
WR moves on nor all thy piety nor wit
can lure it back to cancel half a line
nor all thy tears wash out one word of
it great wisdom isn't it and when you
give up your personal history and I
carried that personal history around
with me for 34 years angry someone once
described resentment as the poison that
you take in order to kill somebody else
the seventh secret of 10 Secrets says
there are no Justified resentments
everything that you justify I have a
right to be happy I have a right to be
unhappy you'll hear people say it all
the time I have a right if you knew who
I was married to you would understand I
have a right to be miserable and they go
around defending their right to be
miserable and when you defend your right
to be miserable you attract exactly what
you're defending into your life
you just keep attracting more and more
of it I had a woman who had been uh
divorced in therapy with me back in the'
70s and she had gone out with four men
since her divorce and all four of the
men had treated her exactly the same
they had been treated her as a sex
object moved on didn't call back were
disrespectful didn't care anything about
her and she said to me I swear to you in
therapy in our last session she said I
want you to talk to all four of those
men and I said there's only one common
denominator in this Rel in this thing
and you have to ask yourself what it is
that you are doing to attract into your
life that which you resent so much
because if well I'll get on get to that
in a moment so when I went to my
father's grave and I stood there I got
rid of the resentment and I walked away
a free man and I suspect that probably
the most influential person in my life
was my father because right after I uh
got rid of all that hatred and that
anger and that bitterness and resentment
and the dreams I used to have about him
and all the things that I just couldn't
understand about how could someone walk
out on such a beautiful woman with three
boys and never even make a phone call if
I don't talk to my kids at 24 hours
wherever I am I get you know I get
nervous I get Twitchy I haven't talked I
got to connect and he went a lifetime
but it was that act of forgiveness I was
overweight at that time right after I
did that I started running and I ran
well I won't even want to tell you how
obsessive I am but I ran 22 years 8 mil
a day and I never missed a day ever in
22 years I shouldn't be so proud of
that but you brush your teeth every day
so that's not obsessive I just ran every
day all right and I was drinking today
I'm a camel you look on my lapel you see
a
camel some of you are applauding and
some of you wondering what the hell is
he talking about a camel is an animal
who starts out every day on his knees
they're wonderful animals and they wake
up every day on their knees and they go
24 hours without a drink and I've been
doing that for a couple of decades now
and um and there was a time when I
didn't and couldn't and wouldn't and so
on and that came about when I emptied my
my heart of resentment I was attracting
the wrong people into my life I was
eating improperly I was putting caffeine
into my body I was a a candidate for
every kind of illness you could imagine
and everything in my life changed
including my writing I walked away from
buxy Mississippi my father's grave in
1974 I went down to Fort Lauderdale
Florida I checked myself into a uh a
hotel and I wrote a book called your
erronous owns in 14 days beginning to
end today there are 32 million copies of
it in 47 languages it happened in one
two we period of abandoning the
resentments via Cananda the great
teacher from India came over when his
devotees said how do I do this how can I
do this how can I get rid of the ego how
can he said you don't have to he said in
the springtime go out and observe the
blossoms on the fruit trees he said the
blossoms vanish of themselves as the
fruit grows so too will the lower self
vanish as the Divine grows within you
you don't have to beat anything out of
you you don't have to defeat anything
you don't have to get it out you don't
have to work on it you just have to let
the Divine grow within you and it will
push out all that has been taken taking
up that room to attract into your life
that which doesn't work so your
soulmates are people who I believe show
up and teach us these things I have six
daughters as I said they are all
incredibly great soulmates they teach me
more than you could ever imagine if I
raise my voice if I do anything in my
home with my children that is
inconsistent with anything I've ever
said
publicly or anything I've ever written
or anything they've ever seen on
television my daughter Serena who is my
ultimate alltime
Supreme
soulmate will put her hand on her hip
and her leg out and run it up and down
like this and respond she said it to me
not long ago I wonder what all those
people would think of Mr positive if
they could see him here this
[Applause]
morning then she asked her sister what
do you think some do you how many books
you think we'd be selling here this
morning they could only see Mr positive
you shut up and do what I tell you
they're great and they're soulmates to
each other favorite line I I follow them
around when I start running out of
material I say come on just say
something stupid come on come on
something anything I need some more
material get out of here Serena came
down for breakfast one morning she was
13 her sister summer was 15 and out of
nowhere summer said to her younger
sister she said if you didn't have any
feet would you wear
shoes I'm standing there I what is this
what and Serena can hardly tolerate
anybody at at 6:00 or 6:30 in the
morning she looked said what are you
talking about that's ridiculous why do
you even talk why do you even breathe
you
know you laugh cuz you've heard
this well you did it some said I just
wanted to know if you didn't have any
feet would you wear shoes that's not
such a bad question she said of course
not summer said then why are you wearing
that
bra off they go
into I said don't chase her that's your
soulmate
she and attached nowhere attached
nowhere letting go of our attachments
letting go of the particularly the need
to be right I've told you one of the
great great lessons I talked about it on
one of my programs is the the four words
you're having a conflict with anyone
you're right about that whatever it is
that anyone is saying to you but you
have to do it in a nice way my wife and
I sort of got it down now you know where
we don't even have to say it we just
hold up four
fingers you're right about that when I
hold up the four fingers she says don't
hold up those damn fingers either I
don't want to know that I'm right cuz I
know you don't believe it now she's
gotten to the point where she can hold
up just one finger you know it's like
when you let other people be right and
you let go of your KNE need to be right
almost all of your attachments disappear
because that's what the ego that's what
the ego does that's what it is it's what
it why that's how it works works on
being right it's attached to being right
and it's willing to it's willing to die
to be right I was at O'Hare Airport one
time and the arm over the parking lot
was broken you know to get out and there
was a guy inside and the cars were
backed up 30 minutes 35 minutes 40
minutes and they couldn't get the arm to
go up I mean they couldn't get and there
must have been 50 cars waiting to get on
with their appointments and finally a
guy about 10 cars up got out I was
walking so I was independent of it and I
he got out picked up the uh arm and then
started to get back in his car and drive
for and the guy jumped in front of his
car and was willing to die to be right
because you don't leave unless you pay
the $3 or whatevers that you owed and he
was willing to give him this he said
here here take what you want I got to go
to work but he was willing to die to be
right the guy almost ran him over too
right the second of these 10 secrets and
I've got to rush through them is um came
to me when I was 19 years old and I uh I
graduated from high school in 1958 and I
joined the Navy to make the world safe
for democracy which I did for 4 years
you notice there were no invasions there
were no Wars between 1958
1962 you laugh but I was out there
making the world safe for democracy and
um I went to a school in Bainbridge
Maryland cryptography school and then I
left there and I flew out to San
Francisco and my Aunt Barbara who taught
at Hayward High School handed me a book
and she said I think it's really
important that you read this book and
the book was written by a man who was at
the time of his life in his life he was
probably the most famous man alive more
famous than the presidents cuz there was
no TV no radio none of that kind kind of
the kind of thing that got information
around the globe the way it does now his
name was Leo Tolstoy and Tolstoy wasn't
just a great writer he was a Mystic he
was a philosopher and he also talked and
wrote about and even lived in areas so
esoteric I mean here they would we'd
give workshops on them but uh in those
days that was considered very far out
and um she handed me this book to read
and I was boarding a a refrigerator ship
in Alama to go for the next 29 days days
to meet my ship the USS Ranger was was
an aircraft carrier in a place called
Sasso on the southern part of Japan so I
was a 19-year-old boy boarding a ship
and I had 29 days because I didn't have
a lot of flights going to Japan in 1958
from San Francisco that required a lot
of stops and they didn't use it for that
that's how they transported us around so
I got about 10 or 11 days out and I
reached in my seabag and I pulled out
this book The Death of Ivan
and I started reading it and Ivan illich
was a man who lived in Moscow he was a
civil servant he went back and forth to
work every day but inside of him he felt
something something that wasn't quite
right he was filling out the forms he
was paying his bills he had three
children he had a wife lived in an
apartment he did everything that he
quote was supposed to be doing and yet
there was a part of him that was um
knowing that he wasn't on purpose
knowing that he wasn't living a
fulfilled life he felt there was a
destiny there was some lying there on
his deathbed looking up at his wife and
as he's about to die he says to his wife
what if my whole life has been wrong and
he closed his eyes and died and that was
the end of the novel and I took out and
I started my journal on the USS Vega at
that time at the age of 19 and I wrote a
note to my myself and it said dear Wayne
I still have it I said don't
die with your music still in you and
that became the second secret of 10
secrets for success and interface don't
die with your music Still In You and
don't let your children by any means
either that this is an intelligent
system that we are all a part of there's
a force in this universe you've heard
workshops about it you've heard people
talking about it I talk about it so many
of my friends here in the front row and
the colleagues of mine here speak about
this thing called Spirit or Soul or
Consciousness and this intelligence that
flows through everything is more than
just something that we pray to and that
we think of in religious context and
that's really the emphasis where I want
to go here with the rest of of my time
here with you this afternoon is to see
and understand that you showed up here
for a reason when my daughter Serena was
complaining to me and bitching about
this and that and she's been doing it
since she was born so she's just good at
it you know I adore this child I mean
because she's my soulmate I want to get
as much as I can from her you know I
said you know Serena I'm tired tired
tired of you telling me what kind of a
father I should be and instead of you
doing that anymore I would like you to
stop right now and take responsibility
yourself for the kind of father I've
become and she looked at me and she did
one of these with the eyes rolled back
she said you want to run that one by me
one more time you want me to be
responsible for what kind of father you
I said exactly I said before you came
into this life you needed to have a
father it's just the way it works and
you needed to have a mother you picked
mom to be your mother you picked me to
be your father and if if you don't like
what it is that I do and how I do it you
shouldn't be blaming me you should be
saying why did I pick this guy anyway to
be my father why did I do that she said
I don't remember any of
this I said it's not about your memory
you don't remember what you had for
breakfast last Thursday you don't
remember living in your mother's tummy
you don't remember living in a crib
there's lots of things you don't trust
you got to trust me on this one I know
what I'm talking about this is an
intelligent system we're all a part of
and you showed up here and in order to
get here you needed parents and you had
the opportunity to pick who you needed
for this journey and this is who you
pick she said so you're telling me that
before I ever even got here I picked you
to be my father I said exactly here's
her classic line I must have been in a
hurry I said well when you're making
really important decisions slow down you
know these are the kind this is the way
my house works this is how I stay
grounded in my life there's a wonderful
poet musician in this country man I
whose music I think is among the finest
ever written his name is Jackson Brown
Jackson uh had an album put out in the
70s called late for the sky and another
one called The Pretender late for the
sky number six is uh something that I
play almost every day it's called for a
dancer and he goes the lyrics go like
this just do the steps that you've been
shown by everyone you've ever known
until the dance becomes your very own
into a dancer you have grown from a seed
someone else is thrown go on ahead and
throw some seeds of your own somewhere
between the time you
arrive and the time you go home because
and here's the kicker because in the end
there is one dance you'll do alone is
that great and all of his music to me is
like that I don't know a song He's
written that doesn't touch my soul and I
i' like to think of yourself and myself
as not being willing to be what others
have dictated to me and as I move into
this whole field of energy and spiritual
solution and intention I'd like you to
just take a minute or two or five and
consider what it is that keeps us from
reaching a level of Consciousness in
which we can play the music that we were
destined to play that we signed up to
play that we came here to play and why
is it that so many of us feel so
frustrated in and come to workshops and
listen to tapes and read books and do
all and and look for advice and get into
therapy and take Prozac and you know I
have a client who I think uses lithium
as a salad dressing you know I mean it's
uh what is because we're just we're
living our lives that are programmed for
us and be become dancers instead of
choreographers instead of going within
and saying Khalil Jabron the famous
Lebanese poet put it this way he said
when you are born your work is placed in
your heart it's here in King Le
Shakespeare says go to thy bosom knock
there and ask your heart what it doth
know ask your heart not here ask your
heart what it doth know and live from
that perspective and if you've got music
to play if you got a Mr Holland's Opus
in you to me a great movie just the kind
of thing that sort of symbolizes what
I'm speaking about and it doesn't have
to be writing a great Opus it doesn't
have to be writing a book for some of
you it is some of you have handed me
copies of manuscript you're going out
there and you're going to do it and I
say go for it publish it yourself figure
it out whatever it is if your heart
tells you this is something you have to
do you're going to get guidance you're
going to get you know dorine will tell
you there's Angels everywhere there's
Angels this is the Angel lady she looks
like an angel she is an angel angel I
love her and you know that and they are
it doesn't matter what you call them I
don't call them Angels but it doesn't
matter if you call what you call them
guidance is there assistance is there
and when you move into intention you
access and negotiate the presence of
guidance and it's available to you and
it'll work for you and it'll keep you
away from your addictions and it'll put
you in the direction of the people that
need to come into your life to help you
I had a reading today
from a lady who blew me away and she was
sent to me through I can't even begin to
tell you the number of people and how it
all worked for her and I to show up and
no I met a woman in Kansas City last
week who said I saw I don't even know
the name of this country I had never
even heard of this country and I used to
teach geography it's movia or mavia or
Mulan or what how do you say it say it
again mavia he formerly part of the
Soviet Union it's a tiny little place
and she saw a story about this and a
little boy's picture flashed on this on
the screen of a something that she was
watching on PBS she said I've got to
adopt a child from that country it
became her Mission she couldn't get it
out of her head don't you have things
like that in you that you feel but and
how often do you act on them or do you
keep yourself from doing it and she went
to movia and she's got a little boy
named Pierce and he's now 4 years old
and it's like every time she sees him
she knows she's on purpose purpose in
her life it doesn't have to be about
creating it can be about anything and if
you get to the end of your life I mean
can there be anything more terrifying
than the idea the kind of that vision of
Ivan illich lying on his deathbed saying
what if my whole life has been wrong I
know that could never happen to me
because I'm doing it right now just
being here being on stage having the
guidance that I have having you here the
whole energy of what goes on when I sit
down to write I know I'm on purpose I
don't worry any longer about whether my
book is going to sell or whether people
are going to like it or whether the
reviews are going to be good or whether
it's going to make this list or that
list it's not even relevant I can't even
conceptualize it I write because when I
see that writing table and it's
surrounded by Angels it's surrounded by
Angelic energy I put books I put
crystals I put everything is possible to
put around there and I wake up I get up
in the morning and I go out and run and
I swim and I am attracted to it I can
feel it pulls me toward it there's such
a and when I let go and surrender and
have no resentments and allow it just
flows the concept of writer's block is
anything I can identify with I don't
know what that means because if I get
tired and stop writing I just have to
reach over and pick up this or pick up
that or the phone will ring or I go down
to the mail or some and whatever it is
that I need it is always there it's like
you can negotiate apprciate the presence
of guidance of higher and faster energy
but you can't do it if you're not on
purpose you can't do it if you're going
to die with your music still in you if
you're living the life that somebody
else orchestrated for you so in 5
minutes let me do what I usually take a
half a day to do hi there my name is Liz
Dawn and I am the co-creator of
celebrate your life events and I hope
you're loving this amazing workshop with
the late and great Dr Wayne Dyer this
was recorded live at one of our
celebrate your life conferences and I'm
so excited that we could share this very
special workshop with all of the Evan
carmichel fans and to learn more about
us just click the link below and visit
celebrate yourlife.com let me give you
what I believe are the significant
things that keep us from moving into
this level the first of these is it all
goes back to a simple thing out of the
Torah out of the Old Testament as a man
thinketh so is he from Proverbs and boy
there's no group that knows more about
that than a group who would have just
been through what you've been through
this weekend it's about the invisible
energy of thought and making it work for
us as a man thinketh so is he we become
what we think about said Emerson all day
long our thoughts create our reality
you've heard it a thousand different
ways the problem is that most people
don't get it that it works both ways it
isn't like you just have to put your
thoughts on what you want and if I put
my thoughts on what I want oh and I just
get into a new age Good Feeling mood
that everything's just going to start
flowing into my life because it's what I
want the fact is if you keep your
thoughts on what you want and what you
think about is what expands want is
what's going to continue to show up in
your life you're just going to have
wants you have to shift off of wants and
into intention but more than that in a
moment the first thing to understand is
that if what you think about is what
expands and you're you're thinking about
what's missing in your life and you talk
about what's missing in your life and in
your daily life you share what's missing
with your friends and your in-laws and
your mother whenever you talk to her and
you talk a lot about what is missing in
your life that's what shows keeps
showing up it's missing in my
relationships it's missing I don't have
any abundance and it's missing in the
kind I don't get this and I don't get
that if that's what you think about and
what you think about is what expands why
wouldn't you expect more of what's
missing to keep showing up in your life
and it will and it does and
self-actualizing people I was blessed to
have a great teacher in my life named Dr
Abraham maslo who died on the very same
day in the same hour that I was
receiving my PhD on the 14th of June in
1970 he died in Meno Park California and
I was walking across the stage and it
was almost as if he passed on a baton
and said I've explained it to the
academics of the world now you take it
to the cab
drivers and the dancers and the teachers
and the parents and uh the musicians and
everybody else this idea of higher
Consciousness and self-actualization and
it gets worse if your thoughts are on
what is not what's missing but what is
and what you think about is what expands
and you don't like what is in your life
guess what you will continue to attract
into your life if what you think about
is what expands and you can only act
upon what you think about and what
you're thinking about are the
circumstances of your life and the
circumstances of your life suck as my
kids would say then you're going to
attract more of suck into your life you
have to because it is out of what you
think about that you manifest and create
it's the way it works don't get mad at
me I'm a reporter here tonight okay I
didn't invent this system I'm just a
part of it and it gets worse if what you
think about is what expands and what you
think about is what always has been and
you despise what always has been you are
going to continue to attract what always
has been into your life even though you
despise it because what you think about
is what expands as a man thinketh so is
he self-actualizing people never ever
talk about what's missing in their life
what's wrong in their life and what
always has been in their life if they
don't like it Einstein said it's the six
secret of success and Inter peat you
cannot solve a problem
with the same mind that created it
everything that shows up in your life in
the form of a problem is something that
you have attracted into your life you
don't have to be guilty about it you
just have to take responsibility and I'm
talking about everything the
circumstances of your life are what you
have attracted into them including your
illnesses no guilt you didn't do
anything bad you're not being punished
you attracted it into your life if you
don't own it and you believe that it
happened because of something external
to yourself then that something external
to yourself is going to have to change
in order for you to get better and the
likelihood of that happening is pretty
small might happen not likely so you
can't put your energy on what is missing
and what is if you don't like what is
and what always has been this is the way
it's always been we've always been poor
we've always been in this business we've
always done things this way there's
always been War how many times have you
heard people say we're going to war
again it's no big deal there's always
been Wars there's always been Wars
there'll always be Wars why would you
want to have an energy that says
there'll always be Wars I don't think
there will always be Wars I think we'll
reach a level of Consciousness in which
Wars will become something that we'll
look back upon and say imagine those
people they actually use violence to
settle their
problems that won't happen why would we
put our thoughts or our energy on
anything that we don't want to manifest
I'm on an airplane changing planes in
Dallas to go to San Francisco for Miami
we've got about 10 minutes to get to our
flight one of those days where things
are not Landing early because or on time
because of storm clouds or something so
I'm sitting next to a lady and I said
I'm going to go I'm going to get up
there now I get my I'm going to I'm
going to go make my she said with my
luck she said I will not make my
connection I'll have to wait here in
Dallas and I said to her with my luck I
will make my
connection she's still in
Dallas why would you want to put out to
the world to the universe to attract
back into your life the idea that with
my luck things won't work out why would
you ever say that where could that come
from how could even if it's just a silly
little offhanded remark why would we
have created off-handed remarks that
reflect things aren't going to work out
for ourselves because these are the
obstacles to higher Consciousness and it
gets even worse you cannot attract into
your life what you intend to manifest if
your thoughts or your
energy are on what they want or expect
for you and there are no shortage of
them if you put your thoughts and your
energy and you talk to your relatives
and you're on the telephone complaining
about and you do this on a regular basis
if you're constantly talking about what
they expect for you this was
particularly relevant when I was working
with young adolescents my mother wants
me to do my father wants and I would
always say to them why do you think
about what they want why don't you put
your attention on what you intend to
create well but I can't do that I can't
I said but if you put your thoughts on
it in your eventually you'll have to act
on it it's like those of you who are
smoking I see some of you smoking
sneaking your cigarettes you're so full
of Shame about your cigarettes out there
you know smoke if you want to smoke you
but if you don't want to smoke or you
think that smoking isn't so put your
thoughts on not smoking see yourself as
a nonsmoker keep smoking that's what you
have to do but keep your energy and your
thoughts on this is something I intend
to no longer do and guess what you will
start attracting the energy to keep you
from smoking before long it'll be very
difficult for you to get cigarettes
you'll go to buy them and they'll be out
of your brand you won't have enough
money with you so so the universe will
start reacting to the intention that you
have and it'll stop you same with
addictions same with losing weight see
yourself looking the way you want to
look keep eating have a hot fud Sunday
if that's what you need to do but put
your thoughts and your attention and
don't ever allow what they want for you
which is what Ivan illage did and most
of this is just relatives relatives are
really good at this having in thoughts
about what you should be I got a a great
idea for a book I got a great title see
what you think of this your friends are
God's way of apologizing for your
relatives what do you
think you see I gave this talk to your
relatives last month and they applauded
too so here we go if you can't put your
thoughts on what's missing and there's
so much missing and you can't put your
thoughts on what is if you don't like
the circumstances of your life and you
can't put your thoughts on what always
has been and you can't put your thoughts
on what others expect for you if you
don't like it what can you think about
where are you going to put your thoughts
how you going to train yourself you
train yourself to place your thoughts
and your energy at all times not on what
you want but on what you
intend to manifest into your life and
now I would like to shift this
presentation over to something called
intention and I'd like to read to you
the thing that got me inspired to write
the next book I'm writing one of my
great teachers Thomas troward his
Edinburgh lectures and Dory lectures
have you read those are you familiar
with those they blow me away and this is
from costan castan and troward have been
constant guides in my life the last few
years in the universe there is an
unmeasurable Indescribable Force which
those who live of the source we call
Sorcerers not Hocus Pocus in anation
Sorcerers but Sorcerers meaning of the
source in the universe there is an
unmeasurable Indescribable Force which
those who live of the source call
intention and that absolutely everything
that exists in the entire Cosmos is
attracted to intent by a connecting link
intention I'm using it in a context that
you may never have thought of before
intention is not what you do intention
is is that which was the future pull
that was in the conceptual seed that
allowed you to come into form in the
first place that there are no mistakes
in this universe that every Acorn has
intent in it it will never become a
watermelon there are no mistakes in it
intent is built into that which
manifests Sorcerers that's all of you
are not only concerned with
understanding and employing that
connecting link but they are especially
concerned with cleansing it of the
numbing effects brought about by the
concerns of living every day at ordinary
levels of consciousness you want to get
to intention I like you to think of
intention as something that you are
connected to because everything in the
universe is connected to intent and that
intention is not something that you do
with your will you can match your will
to the will of God or you can match your
intent to the intention that is a force
in the universe but it is not an ego
thing at all you don't get to do it and
that I'd like you to think of intention
like when my mother used to come and get
us when I was a little boy I can
remember being maybe three and we lived
I lived in Mount Clemens at that time
with my brother and uh my mother would
come and get us and she'd take us on the
street car on the east side of Detroit
we called them the trolley and the
trolley I would sit there and and I
would look up and they had these straps
coming down from the ceiling of the
trolley and I would look up at that
trolley strap and I would think wow what
would it be like to be so tall to be
able to stand down there and reach up
and take a hold of that trolley strap I
could never do it cuz I was too little
I'd like you to think of a force of
intention a field of intention that is
just 3 ft above your grasp no matter how
high you jump I I can jump
but I'm white so I'm limited okay so uh
White Men Can't We you know we can't
jump right so how I don't care if you're
Michael Jordan all right however high
you can jump 3 ft above that there's a
field an energy field that you cannot
jump to you cannot get there with this
with this body and when you jump to this
you keep jumping you'll always just
it'll just elude you so what we have to
do is figure out a way to float up to
intent and this trolley strap is
connected to intent or intention to a
force field in the universe and if you
can figure out a way to leave your body
and in your mind float up and get a hold
of this trolley strap of intention it
will take you wherever you are destined
to go with all of the people wherever it
stops to pick up that you need to take
with you on the Journey of the trolley
and the right people will show up and
some will they be there for a little
while then they'll get off then they'll
leave and others will come in and
replace them and you are always sort of
hanging on to this thing called intent
now the reason that you can't get a hold
of intention is because you're in ego of
Consciousness now you can check into any
Hospital in this country and get a
tonsilectomy you can get an appendectomy
but you can't get an ego ectomy they
just don't offer them all right and an
ego ectomy is what we need not to get
rid of it but just to tame it the ego
has six components here they are are in
a nutshell a belief that I am what I
have a belief that I am what I do what I
accomplish a belief that I am my
reputation what others think of me
that's the ego a belief that I am
separate from you a belief that I am
separate from what I would like to
attract into my life I'm separate from
it it's separate from me and six a
belief that I am separate from God those
are the six Comm components of the ego
when you let go of those ideas and see
yourself not as separate from God but as
a piece of God as always connected I am
in you and you are in me and I am in the
father and the father is in you you know
the most misconstrued line in the
history of Christianity is Jesus saying
it is only through me that you will come
to know the father that we as human
beings having a spiritual experience
interpreted Jesus who came here
calibrated at 1,000 as a spiritual being
who said it's the spirit that gives life
the flesh counts for nothing this
doesn't count when he said me he wasn't
speaking about his beard and his sandals
and his arms and his legs that human
being he was speaking as that which is
in all things I am in you how can my
body my physical body be in your body
how can I be in all of you you if I'm
talking about the spirit it's that which
is in all things and we have created a
catechism of exclusion to the extent of
murdering Millions upon Millions upon
millions of people in the name of you
have to take and believe in this body
rather than the spirit which he emanated
from and described and lived from so
intention is something that we can
connect to now here's what my take on
intention and I'm conscious of the time
I've got four more days worth to do in a
half hour okay intention is this Force
View and I'd like to suggest to you that
there's nothing in this universe that
doesn't have intent in it as I just read
that quote observation to you and that
you are no exception if there is no
place that intention is not if there's
no place that it is not if it's in every
living thing it must be in you and if it
is in you and there's no place that it's
not it must also be in whatever is
missing from your life in some way
you're already connected to what is
missing because there's no place that
it's not you share this right now my
heart is being beaten or is beating by
an energy and it's beating everybody
else's heart in this room as well and it
beats everybody else's on this planet as
well we share that energy energ it's
growing your fingernails I used to say
it it's growing our hair but I've lost
faith in that
one actually it still grows it it just
grows it in other funny places all
right now here's what I think this is
the meat of intention as I move off now
into energy you look at what it is that
when when did you begin you're a
scientist you look at what began you and
you go back and you say well there was a
seed
there was a drop of human protoplasm
that collided with another drop a seed
was formed a tiny microscopic seed was
formed and that's called your conception
in a moment of your parents Amore right
and that's where you began but then you
take that seed that began you at your
conception and you put it to the
microscopic test and you turn up the
magnification and you see that in that
seed that began you there was something
called call a molecule and if you take a
molecular microscope and turn up the
magnification all you're doing is
looking to find out where did the seed
come from how did this thing called you
which had in it your height your weight
the color of your skin when you were
born when you will die it had everything
that is physical about you was in that
seed it's a miracle it's miraculous none
it's Goda we can't figure it out a heart
starts beating inside of a mother's womb
6 weeks after that moment it's a total
mystery to everybody on the planet we
have no idea but we do know that if you
turn up the magnification and try to
study where that seed came from we see
first molecules inside the molecules we
see atoms in an atomic microscope in
inside of the atoms we see electrons
neutrons protons croutons all of these
things we memorized in grade school
right we take the electron with an
electron microscope trying to find out
where did the seed that I first started
started with where did it come from
what's its source we take this electron
microscope we turn up the magnification
we study it at the quantum level and we
find out there are tiny little particles
in there called quarks and we take these
quarks mostly we have spaces we take
these quarks and we put them right here
in this state into a particle
accelerator we rev them up at
250,000 mph we Collide
them we open up the particle accor
accelerator and we look inside and
there's nothing there there's no
particles there there's only energy pure
energy no particles St Paul told us
about it 2,000 years ago before quantum
physics was even thought of that which
is seen hath not come from that which
doth appear the source of everything
particles cannot create more particles
Dr Hawkins lectures I've sat through
three of them this in the last few all
substantiate this idea
that out of here's here's how it's
quoted in the bhavat Gita here's the
source speaking I am the source of all
spiritual and material worlds everything
emanates from me that's the voice of the
creative Divine organizing intelligence
that we call God or Soul or Spirit now
this isn't even anything that you needed
to know the Intriguing thing about it is
that what you needed for this physical
Journey was not only in that seed that
is physical and a particle but when you
look for its source what you needed for
this physical Journey was in the energy
that allowed the seed to come into
emanation into creation into form in the
first place that your source for looking
the way you look and showing up when you
showed up was in something that has no
boundaries and more than that what
really intrigues me the most is that
what you needed for this journey in an
emotional sense what your purpose is
every thought that you have all of the
emotional experiences of your life all
of your goals all of your aspirations
all of your dreams all of this stuff
that emanates from this human thing that
you're in the ghost in the machine all
of that was in this energy that is
formless before it came into a seed so
that the question to ask yourself about
intention is how did I get off of
intention how did I get off of what was
in the energy that allowed me to become
the seed that allowed me to become the
being that I am how come I'm not
fulfilling a magnificent Destiny how
come I'm not doing what Jesus said even
the least among you can do all that I
have done and even greater things how
come I'm not doing that and I have the
answer but it's too good you got to pay
more I'm sorry it's too good torine take
up a collection here will this is too
good I want to just share this with you
the reason why you got off of what it is
that your intent had for you in the
energy before you even came into this
physical world is that you moved out of
harmony with that which created you when
you leave your Source you lose the power
of your Source when you connect back to
your source that invisi from which
everything emanates you regain the power
of your Source you could do anything
intention is nothing more than moving
into harmony with what it is that
created you in the first place and it's
not physical which we've just
demonstrated so if you had magic
binoculars and you could take those
binoculars out and you could look at
intention you could see it you just get
a picture of what it looks like I
believe that there are faces of
intention I've just written a chapter
called the seven faces of intention I'm
not going to go into all of them I just
want to share with you what I believe
this organizing Spirit called God or
Soul or spirit this principle that
allows something to go from formless to
form from boundaryless to boundary from
nowhere n o w h e r e to now hear n o w
h e r e just the the same just a little
difference in spacing and you get into
now here and you look at now here and
you say where is this thing going it's
going nowhere just watch it it was
here's the way William Blake put it to
see the world in a grain of sand and a
heaven in a wild flower to hold eternity
in the palm of your hand hand and
infinity in an hour we are all led to
believe a lie when we see with not
through the eye which was born in a
night to perish in a night while the
soul slept in beams of light you were
all born in a night to perish in a night
everything on this planet was but there
is something that we have got missing so
if there is an organizing Spirit not if
there is there is what does it look like
here's what it looks like I'm going to I
give you just three there's seven maybe
a thousand the first is that it is
creative somehow this Force wants to
create if it didn't it wouldn't there
would be no creation when you leave
creativity and creation ideas behind you
and do what others tell you to do you
have detached yourself from Spirit from
the organizing intelligence every time
you're not created and following out
what somebody else thinks you should do
you have left the Rapport the harmony
that you need you have left being what
God is and turned yourself into
something that some ego body has said
you should be you cannot manifest
attract into your life what you want
live at the highest levels of
consciousness if you are not creative
not creating the spirit is all that
creates secondly all that is created has
to to be kind if you could see God if
you could just could just see this
Spirit you would see something that why
would the Creator force that brings
anything into creation creat something
and then not want it to live and to
survive and to be and to thrive and to
be happy and so why would it want to do
that it would just create some and say
ah the hell with that I don't want it
doesn't do that it is kind you want to
hear an amazing research study they just
discovered that when a person is a
recipient
of kindness any act of kindness that you
receive in your life a simple act I was
watching Dr Hawkin speak today and a
woman a pregnant woman came in there I
hope she was
pregnant I've made that mistake
before and she there was no chairs left
and there was a man sitting there and he
just got up and he walked to the back he
said here you take my chair an act of
kindness okay her serotonin levels were
increased you know it's serotonin the
enzyme in the brain that's what proac
does that's what Wellbutrin does that's
what selexia does that's all of these
things that are we call anti-depressants
they just stimulate the growth of
Serotonin an enzyme in the brain that
makes you feel like you have peace of
mind all right so that an act of
kindness increases serotonin levels in
the body number one and number two it
increases the strength of the immune
system if you are the recipient of an AC
of kindness and you feel that which is
what the creative spirit is kind it's
always kind then you will have your
immune system which is designed to help
you to overcome disease processes
strengthened Now The Giver of the act of
kindness the provider of the ACT has his
serotonin levels increased and has his
immune system strengthened so that in
any act of kindness the recipient and
the provider both of them have this
physiological reaction that they just
measured but the Intriguing thing is
that anybody who observes that who is in
the energy field to observe the act of
kindness has their serotonin levels and
their immune system strengthened
research-wise at the same level as the
two participants the act of observing
acts of kindness impact us physically
who was the person was there anybody
here who wanted there was a couple of
things you wanted to buy in the
bookstore but you you were like a $100
short and you couldn't do it and you
didn't have the money and you who was it
was anybody like that was that you
pardon it was jewelry how much were you
short 100 come on up here come here come
up here this is an order this is God
speaking all
right can you walk I know you don't want
my money but you're going to have to
take it come over here I brought this
for you this is an act of kindness are
you going to allow me to do it I want
you to buy your jewelry with the this
today that's for you okay it's real now
what just
happened sarona how do you feel how do
you feel she's throwing kisses I feel
the same way Kundalini going up my back
and guess what everybody in the room has
the same reaction an act of kindness the
third of these qualities is and there's
others as well the third is called
Beauty all all that is coed from the
formless to the form to the seed is
first of all has to be created secondly
it has to be put into a salubrious
environment for it to survive it wants
to survive and three it is a beautiful
or attractive nothing is created why
would the creative Spirit create
something that it thought was
unattractive that it thought was useless
that it didn't think was was beautiful I
have been quoting a poem 25 years I
wrote about it in wisdom of the ages a
young Victorian poet named John Keats
considered by many to be the greatest
poet of of an entire Century died at the
age of 25 and owed to a Grecian earn
truth truth is God truth is fat from
which everything emanates truth and God
and intention are all synonyms beauty is
truth to watch the legendary Earl
Nightingale Strangest Secret check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'd like to tell you
about The Strangest Secret in the world
not long ago Albert schwitzer the Great
doctor and Nobel Prize winner was being
interviewed in London and a reporter
asked him doctor what's wrong with men
today